some moves around the field it can
impact
neighbor it was very effective on
killing weed seeds and quite a few
Growers would use it before they plant
strawberries because it would kill the
we pathogens but we don't really have
that option
anymore a lot of girls are interested in
black plastic as a way of managing weeds
as well and strawberries in this case
and black plastic Works fairly well in
annual systems where you plant your
strawberries in the
fall after the long day lengths induce
Runing so you plant them in the fall
they don't Runner anymore they just go
through the fall and get exposed to
short days and cool temperatures and
induce flowers the following spring
those uh flowers open and and they set
fruit and fruits harvested early in the
spring and then the plants are ripped
out and it's cycle starts all over again
this is the annual system that you would
see in California and Florida and some
Growers are trying this black plastic
system up north here in New York too the
challenges with that are that in the
fall when you plant your strawberries
oftentimes we don't have a very long
period of cool warm temperatures in the
fall for those plants to get established
and initiate flower buds so they often
don't do so well the following spring
even though it's a pretty good way of
managing the weeds the black plastic
also has a big environmental impact too
and you don't really have a good way of
getting rid of the plastic once it's in
the ground and then the second year when
the strawberries do try to produce
Runners there's no place for those
Runners to root because the Plastics in
the way you have to either cut them off
or rip up the plastic that's a problem
as well and I did some calculations
earlier and strawberry Growers use
enough plastic each year to circle the
Earth 13 times that's a lot of plastic
that strawberry Growers use using so I'm
not a real big proponent of black
plastic on strawberries
that most of the growers in the
Northeast use a matted row and here they
plant their strawberries in the
springtime about 18 inches apart down a
row the rows are about four feet apart
they plant into a ESS site that's
prepared it's a real nice seed bed but
if you look at this field you can see
there's a lot of opportunity there are a
lot of initials for weeds to
grow there's not a lot of shading the
plants are small and lots of open ground
for weeds to grow typically what happens
is grow U Growers walk along and they
clip off those first flowers to promote
Runing so the idea is the runners then
will grow down the row and root and form
a nice mat hence the word matted row but
as you can see through all these
pictures there's bare ground throughout
much of that first year you know Growers
irrigate those plants as a runner to
establish but often times with all that
be ground you get a lot of
weeds be a real mess and indeed
strawberry Growers struggle uh endlessly
with weeds particularly under the Mad
Rose system so a lot of people think
well you know I can't have any weeds I
have to spend a lot of time out there
making sure there are absolutely no
weeds in my strawberries and that could
be a strategy to take although that's
very labor intensive but we wanted to
ask a few questions like how much we
growth is acceptable I mean can you
tolerate some weed growth if so how long
can you have weeds in your field before
you have to get them
out we a dead weed uh there are times
when weed growth can be tolerated and
there are times when it can't be
tolerated they're just too competitive
with strawberry plants so we thought
before we really start tackling this
whole problem of managing weed we ought
to be able to answer some of these
questions
questions we did an an experiment and
this experiment was take a planting of
strawberries newly planted field and let
the weeds grow for certain periods of
time and at certain times during that
first year so in this experiment we had
weeds growing for just the month of
June July August September or no weeds
at all throughout the entire year or we
had two week periods June and July July
and August August September three Monon
periods and for the entire season and
then we followed the yield of these
strawberry plants for the next couple of
years here's our plots you can see some
plots have weeds some don't depending on
the month of the
year and here's our graph of some of our
results over here on the left you can
see the X's indicate when weeds are
present this column here is Runners it
indicates how many Runners were
formed after those weed treatments are
present and then the yield the following
year and what you can see in this first
line is when you have weeds throughout
the whole first year you have very few
Runners and very low yield you back off
in the
weeds your yield goes up a little bit
back off a little bit more your yield
goes up a little bit if you only have
weeds during the month of June your
yields are higher and of course that
sort of makes intuitive sense but the
thing that's really interesting I think
is if you look at weeds in June or July
or August September and look at the
runners and look at the yield you can
see that early season weeds have a much
larger impact on yield and Runners
negative impact than do late season
weeds fact weeds in September there's
some small impact on Runner maybe not
much of an impact at all on yield so
weeds in the early part of the season
are much more detrimental than weeds at
the end of the season and we can look at
June and July weeds a two-month period
and look at our yield of a thousand
grams per plot and look at weeds during
a two-month period at the end of the
season down here and our yield is two
and a half times as much even though the
time of weed pressure was exactly the
same we can do the same thing with three
months of weed pressure early weeds low
yield three months of weeds at the end
of the later in the season the yields
are much higher so pretty clear to us
that those early season weeds in a
strawberry field are the most critical
and the ones we have to deal with the
most that's bottom line
here so we also know that we don't have
a lot of herbicides that work very well
on strawberries so the question is can
we use something else besides herbicides
like cultivation to remove weeds early
in the season when they're most
problematic we looked at a bunch of
different cultivation tools to see what
impact that would have on the
strawberries and on the weeds in the
planting
year this is a traditional instrument
that's used to manage we is a rototiller
or a multiv Vader it goes through and
cultivates the weing know I'm sure
you've all seen this the disadvantage of
a multiv Vader is it's very hard on soil
structure because when those times come
down into the soil it compacts the soil
two or three inches down on the ground
then it also on the upstroke it brings
up new weed seeds so even though you
work the weeds in you're also bringing
new weed seeds up because you're working
a soil down you know three or four
inches and it's hard in the structure
there's some other tools out there that
some of the vegetable Growers use that
don't cultivate down so deeply and get
weeds out right between the row one's a
finger weeder you can see it here
working on
some along and pulls the weeds out right
around the
plants there are also these Flex Harrows
and they can be driven right over top of
the plants and these timeses vibrate and
they shake out the small weeds as you
drive quickly over the field so the
strawberry plants can be right in the
ground you can drive right over here
those things wiggle back and forth and
vibrate strawberry plants stay intact
but any small weeds get vibrate out of
the ground you can set those to
different tensions and so forth take out
weeds of different sizes
this is our Reggie weer it goes in the
back of a tractor you sit in the back of
it and it has two
rotating discs down here with tines on
them that spin the weeds out and the
operator moves arms in and out to go
around the
plant and see here these spin like this
as you go around the plant so you can
get close to the plant far away from the
plant close and it only cultivates down
about an inch or so so the nice thing
about this instrument is it does not
compact the soil deeply it doesn't bring
up new weed seeds it just spins the
weeds out from around the
plant instrument is a brush ho it's like
a giant street sweeper it has a couple
of gaps in it that straddle the
strawberry plants and you can in your
case it's cabbage but you straddle the
rows and it just sweeps the weeds right
out of the ground it also creates a lot
of dust the dust settles back down on
the ground but that dust acts as a mulch
and covers up weed seeds so even though
it only cultivates really between the
rows it also suppresses weeds between
the plants as
well these are used a lot on vegetables
we wanted to see how they would work on
strawberry so this is a PL of strawberry
where we used a brush ho to sweep on
either side of the strawberry plants
with no cultivation or anything in
between the rows and it does a pretty
good
job this is Devol which is a standard
herbicide that would be used after
strawberry plant and you can see there's
you know weeds coming up there because
Devol is a pre-emergent herbicide it
doesn't get all the weeds but it gets
many of them but not all of them so
compared to the previous picture where
you use a cultivation tool the herbicide
you doesn't work quite as
well here's a flex T Harrow that was the
one that drags over top of the plants it
vibrates it doesn't pull the plants out
of the ground but it shakes the weeds
loose and it looks pretty good early in
the
season but later in the season we get a
lot of weed seed germination with this
Flex T Harrow because it doesn't bury
the weed seeds it just sort of stirs
them up a little bit even though it
takes the weeds
out when you stop using it then you get
a big flush of weeds and with
strawberries when they start to Runner
you can't use the flex Ty harl after
that because it'll tear the runners out
of the ground so you have to stop and
you get this big flush of weed so by the
end of the season our Flex time harop
plots are fairly
weedy again this is a brush hoe after
we've gone through early in the
season no herbicides just a brush ho and
this is a brush ho later in the season
so unlike the flex H Harrow which gave
us a big flush of weeds same plot same
year the brush ho kept the weeds of
bay so these cultivation tools these
Flex T Harrow seems to work pretty well
here's the flex T Harrow had lots of
weeds in the row and between the
row
see Rush ho had very few weeds in the
row and between the
row that seems like a pretty promising
implement the herbicide gave us quite a
few
weeds so we weren't quite as excited
about
that and if you look at yields it's
interesting where we use the multiv
Vader which is the standard Implement
our yields were you know kind of on the
low side the flex H Harrow where we kept
the weeds out early but we had a stop
later on actually the yields are pretty
good even though they were pretty weedy
at the end of the year again I think
that ties in with what we talked about
earlier that early season weeds if you
get those out of there uh that's a you
do a pretty good job
of G having your plants healthy going
into the year and the yields are pretty
high weeds later on don't matter so much
these plots had weeds later on but you
can see it didn't matter so much brush
ho yes Marvin can can I interrupt with
one question Jeff Miller is wondering if
there's any research on flamers um like
pros and cons and I'm sorry I just saw
that and I I thought I should yeah so
people have played around with flamers
but the thing you don't want to do with
a flamer is obviously burn the leaves of
the strawberry plant so you have to
focus that between the rows of
strawberries and indeed it it works as
long as you have annual plants or I'm
sorry annual weeds but if you have
prenal weeds it doesn't do a very good
job against them because they come
right right back and I really don't know
of anyone who is using flamers on
strawberry in the planting year some
people have experimented with the flamer
in the fruiting year like after harvest
to renovate and clean things up but they
seem to have damaged the plants and they
haven't gotten particularly good results
from using the flamers so I I just
haven't seen it
used so the brush ho and the finger weer
were more expensive to use because
there's a pretty expensive piece of
equipment application they're much more
effective at controlling weeds and over
the long run the brush ho is probably
cheaper certainly cheaper to use labor
wise than our standard practices because
it requires fewer passes fewer hand
weeding no Urban side and if I had a lot
of money and I was a strawberry grower I
think a combination of a brush ho and a
Reggie weeder would just be the trick a
brush ho to sweep the weeds up between
the rows and the Reggie weeder to go
along the plants down the row and I do
have a Reggie weeder home I haven't uh
gotten a brush ho but uh these in
implements are quite good because they
do control weeds early in the season and
they cultivate very shallowly and the
plants really respond to that and seem
to uh grow
well shift slots just a little bit to
blueberries although and you took this
poll but managing weeds in blueberries
is is quite a bit easier than it is in
strawberries the reason for that is
because we can plant perennial rye or
some type sort of a grass between the
rows of
blueberries our blueberries and then
mulch underneath those plants and we can
confine any herbicides to the plants to
that row that mulch row and we don't
really need a lot because the mulch
suppresses a lot the annual weeds and
then we can just mow the weeds off
between a row and so that works pretty
well most blueberry Growers they keep on
top of the weeds don't really have too
many troubles if things get out of hand
they get some vines in there and some
trees you
know but with blueberries you also have
the option with some of those Woody
perennials of going in in early November
with some Roundup and spot spraying it
doesn't seem to hurt the blueberries too
much as long as you're careful you can
in a pry weeds so blueberries is not too
difficult so the question is can we take
that concept and what works well for
blueberries and sort of apply that to a
crop like strawberry in other words can
we think about not doing so much
cultivation where we do bring up weed
seeds and think of it more of a system
where we plant an undisturbed soil like
we do here for blueberries and use a alt
again another Blueberry Field here with
you know fairly clean grass roads mulch
minerals take this concept to
strawberries and see if something might
work for them as well so what we did
here we took various cover crops and we
planted those cover crops in the fall we
let them go through the winter and then
the following spring we killed the cover
crops and we did that from different
ways uh some of them we had to use
Roundup to kill the cover crop others we
could just mow them and they would
die and other we sprayed paraquat on
them because they were annual and once
you kill them they wouldn't come back so
we had these essentially these dead
cover crops in the spring and then we
cultivated narrow
strips on these cover
crops and then we
planted narrow strips and we didn't
disturb the area in between the rows
up weed seeds and we wanted to suppress
weed seed
germination other thing we did here
between Rose is we also came in with uh
some malt between the rows and we
planted the strawberries at a fairly
close density because given the fact
that there's undisturbed soil around
here the runners would have a hard time
rooting so instead of asking the plant
to make a lot of Runners we just planted
the plants closer together figuring it's
cheaper to buy a few more plants than it
is to spend a lot of money weeding so he
wanted to see how that would work and
I'm not going to show you data but I'm
going to show you pictures and here are
some strawberry plants planted through a
rye cover crop that was
killed the strawberries were planted
fairly close spacing in a narrow strip
and then we came in with a little bit of
straw mulch and put over top of that
killed Rye so there was Rye plus there
was a little bit of R straw added to
give a little bit more
biomass this is in a really weedy
Fil A lot of nutsedge and those of you
who familiar with nut sge know that it's
just a terrible weed it's it's very uh
aggressive and it pushes up through
plastic and everything but if you see
where the arrows are here these
plots had no
herbicide and all they had was killed
dry with straw mulch over top of it and
the plants were a relatively high
density and they did extremely well at
least in keep terms of keeping the weeds
down
so this system here I think has some
promise especially on lighter soils
where you can get in and get those
strawberries into the ground at a higher
density so how I get in
there so okay okay so I wanted to show
you this is a a a row a conventional
planning that we use herbicides and
everything like that on and this is with
the mulches and the weeds are pretty
good in both cases so these uh
highdensity plannings with a sod mulch
work I think pretty well or at least
equivalent to what the standard way of
growing
strawberries now we can apply that same
principle
to raspberries we have some good data to
show that raspberries really really uh
thrive in their strong mulch in the
planting year not in subsequent years
but in the planting year raspberries
like to be surrounded by malt just like
I showed you for those strawberries so
this would be a typical way we might
recommend Growers plant raspberries you
know two or three feet apart down the
road with trickle irrigation and straw
mulch around the plants because I love
that straw
molds Marvin could I interrupt to um
just quickly we have another question
about using oats as a cover crop and
whether or not you could also use a
roller crimper on the Rye and maybe you
will be talking about that yeah I'll try
to get to both of those questions in the
next couple
minutes so we
haven't tried crimping the Rye uh but we
have treated it with paraquat or Roundup
because that way we pick up a few extra
weeds along the way but I think you
probably could crimp the Ry as long as
you're doing at the right stage where it
kills it what we did in this experiment
was we wanted to see if we could grow
the mulch in place when we planted the
raspberries so that we wouldn't have to
bring the straw in so here's a plot you
can see some of these plots here where
we had you know be
ground be ground and we had Rye then we
planted the
raspberries down the rows here to see
how they would do
here are the little raspberry plants
growing between that killed rye and then
we follow them for a couple of years and
it's interesting this photo here was
taken two years after the Rye was
planted and you can here are the control
plots where we had that bearr and here
are the plots where we had the Ry and
even though everything was treated
exactly the same in those two plots you
can see big differences between where we
had the Ry here and where we didn't have
the r here it's really remarkable so
that planting through that rye residue
had a really big impact on the
raspberries no difference in yield but
the weed pressure was certainly greater
where we did not use the R so that was I
thought pretty
dramatic now back to Jeff's question
about the could you also use some sort
of a oat cover crop wall now oats die in
the winter time so if you plant Rye if
you plant oats in the Winter or I'm
sorry in the fall and let them go
through the winter by the time spring
comes around there's not a lot of
residue there you could plant through it
but it's not a lot of residue I'm not
sure if it would be enough to really
suppress weeds whereas Rye gives you
more residue and is a little pathic and
suppresses weeds what we have done with
oats what we have done with Sudan grass
is after renovating strawberries we've
gone in and just
broadcast the seed over top of the
strawberry field so instead of going
through and having bare soil from say
August through October again more
opportunities for weeds to germinate
the idea was why not sew a seed in there
at least a plant that we know is going
to die in the winter time and not going
to go to seed so we over broadcast the
oats we broadcast the sedan grass they
grow they displace the weeds that
normally would grow and then they die in
the winter and leave us with a residue
between the strawberry plants
but no weeds and it looks pretty trashy
in the fall when you do that after the
frost comes but it does a pretty good
job of keeping the weeds out as
well so those are some of the approaches
we've used to trying to manage weeds and
strawberries again this is the
strawberry field in the spring after we
grew the Sudan grass between the Rosa
strawberries and it looks pretty clean
so here are some sort of new ways we're
thinking about managing weeds without
relying on herbicides all the time using
cover crops to reduce weed pressure
before planting focus our attention
early in the season if you have limited
time focus at early rather than late
some options are planning through killed
sods using shallow cultivation tools and
interplanting cover crops and that may
hold some promises opposed to going in
there with sinbar or something like that
after
renovation so with that Laura I think
we're done with the formal presentation
and U maybe we can go and look at some
of the responses to the poll or
answerers some questions and Jeff asks
What's the timing of sewing the O of
Sudan grass we uh plant or see that
right at renovation so that would be
probably early August after the you go
through with the Rota tiller and narrow
up the rows the Leer mode off you narrow
up the rose then you can seed your oats
and Sudan grass then if it's a really
hot
warm summer late at the end of the
season the Sudan grass can grow pretty
pretty tall so when we've done that
we've had pretty good results just to go
in with like a sickle bar or something
and mow that Sudan grass back down to
say a foot high if it exceeds the
strawberry plants by too much in other
words it'll shade the strawberry plants
out if it gets too tall so we don't let
it get too tall but if we just go in and
mow it that's a good way of setting it
back again and uh having it sort of
start over again and still provide that
biomass that we want later in this
season
all right does anybody else have any
questions now's your
chance okay maybe we can look at the
results of the poll
um try to find the one that uh but we'll
just start with this one and this is
uh just see gu the results there
hopefully you're seeing the
results and
uh that was the one chose oh yeah this
was the one that we couldn't yeah this
isn't very appropriate so let's get
let's get rid of this one let's look at
um what type of let me just broadcast
the results and what type of new
herbicide would be most useful to
Strawberry Growers and I don't know if
you want to comment at all on that
Marvin yeah would say that I would agree
that post emergent Broad Leaf is
probably most valuable it's not too
difficult to kill grass in strawberries
because grass is a monocot and it's a
grass and you can find selective
herbicides against grasses that leave
the strawberries alone but where you
have real difficulty are broadleaf weeds
within a broadleaf plant most of the
broadleaf herbicides that are out there
affect strawberries as well one of the
few that dozen is 24d surprisingly 24d
will impact most other broadleaf plants
and leave strawberries alone it's very
old herbicide Growers have used it for
years and it's still really quite a good
herbicide to use on strawberries
particularly uh at renovation time and
again in early November when it's still
a little warm and the Dand lines and
plants like that can take it up yeah
anything that works on broadleaf plants
that selectively leave strawberries
alone would be a good thing all right
when I as I switch these pole um things
there's a couple of other questions um
Marvin one from Jeff Miller about can
cover crops be a host of pest of
strawberries and then Jan beglinger has
a um question as
well yeah so cover crops can be host of
pests but if you select a cover crop
that's not closely related to the crop
then the odds of sharing pests diminish
considerably and that's why most of the
cover crops that we've talked about
are grass type crops in the grass family
so Sudan grass it doesn't really share
any pest strawberries in fact it helps
suppress
nitas Rye oats those things they do not
share pest with strawberries so they're
very safe to use whereas if we would be
using say like a legume cover crop like
Clover or peas they do Harbor lots of
diseases in common with strawberries
because they're much more closely
related verticillium Wilt tares plant
bug things like that so stick the
grasses and you'll be much safer and
then in terms
of fact sheets we have good information
in the production guides the strawberry
production guide the blueberry guide the
raspberry guide they all have a a
chapter in there a section on cover
crops that are appropriate to use in the
various Berry
crops what percent of non-h harvest
labor expenditures do you believe
Growers spend on weed management
and yeah I would we've done various
economic analyses and in fact last two
weeks I've taken my class on field trips
to strawberry farms and we've asked the
Growers that question specifically and
they all say about
80% and our numbers when we look at it
the economics it looks like it's about
70% so it's very very high a lot of
Labor spent pulling weeds and managing
weeds and strawberries in particular
that's why we're focusing so many of our
efforts on
strawberries okay um let's look at these
polls about uh how effective the current
Suite of f herbicide
strawberries yeah
raspberries and blueberries and let me
just make sure that they're all um
broadcast the results of all of these as
we look at
them and I would you know concur with
these results at least that's how I
would expect them to come out even if
you pull it a bunch of Growers that you
know strawberry herbicides are modly
effective they're more now than there
were just a few years ago uh same with
raspberries moderately effective none
are super effective but blueberries you
know we have a few that are you know
fairly effective on blueberries because
we have a a plant that's up harded has
Woody stems and shoots so it gives us a
lot more options for spraying a little
bit more harsher product down on the
ground and not affecting the
plant all right and for our final
question this was
actually the first question broadcast
those results
yeah and uh again I think people's
perception is right you know strawberry
Growers struggle the most with weeds
compared to the other
two and then I see a few questions down
here that we can maybe answer about
cover crops the Sarah managing cover
crops book is a good resource and it
sure is a lot of the information from
the Sarah guide we've picked out cover
crops that would be in at sbbook for the
production guide because certain ones
don't do well like it's in the sbook
like some of the legumes but in a
blueberry field where you have an acidic
soil the legumes don't grow well in
acidic soil so those would be excluded
even though they might be good cover
crops otherwise so if you look in a
blueberry production guide it won't talk
about leguminous cover crops because
it's just not compatible with acidic
soil and the question that Dean asks can
buckwheat be used as a late cover at
renovation or their pest
concerns the problem that we've seen
with buckweed is that it it throws a
good bit of shade and it also goes to
seed and the and you might have to kill
it or cultivate it before it goes to
seed whereas the oats and the sedan
grass we don't have to worry about that
we let that Frost take care of it for us
and we can just leave it in plays if you
use buckwheat in between the rows you'd
have to manage a little bit more
carefully because you wouldn't want to
it to turn into a weed for you the
following year I'm not sure about pest
concerns of buckweed I don't think there
would be pest concerns particularly you
know when it's flowering it's flowering
after strawberries flow so even if it
would attract Carnage plant bugs or
something like that it would be past the
point at which strawberries are
vulnerable and then I see Jeff has a is
asking about sap Beetle I'm not sure in
what context but sap beetles do over
winter in strawberry can overwinter in
Strawberry Fields if there's a lot of
junk around so there could be an issue I
suppose if you had a lot of residue it
could make an environment a little bit
more favorable for the sap Beetle to
overwinter in so instead of leaving the
field into the woods and all it might
just hang around that's a good question
I don't know the answer to that I
haven't had
anybody say or observe any grower say
you know I've been multim more and I've
been using these interplanet cover and I
just noticed my saple uh increasing
dramatically I haven't heard that but I
think theoretically it's
possible all right does anybody else
have any questions for
Marvin do want to let you know that we
have another webcast training on October
8th at 1:00 again it'll be the same
format but a different topic I believe
that one is with Dr Courtney Weber about
new um small fruit
varieties and um I I am hopeful that I'm
going to be able to email you folks a
couple of questions just about the
format and whether or not the thing went
smoothly the whole webcast went smoothly
and if you wanted to make any
suggestions please don't hesitate to
email me and I appreciate you thank you
very much Dr pritz for participating and
uh thanks to the rest of you for joining
us and we'll see you in two weeks thank
you